in the morning during the work week i
usually wake up around 7 am and then
slowly get myself ready for work i'm
grateful for my wife who usually
prepares breakfast for me in the morning
she's a bit more of a morning person
than i am so she wakes up already a bit
earlier gets everything ready and then
often also joins me for the breakfast
and of course black coffee is very much
appreciated this way i then get myself
ready grab my bag and leave the house
towards my work i live in munich and my
work is in munich as well so it's a
short commute that i do every day to get
there
usually i take the bicycle but recently
it got stolen so at the moment i take
the s-bahn and the u-bahn to get to work
so public transit which takes me about
20 minutes every day to get there and
then 20 minutes to get back as well i
work for building radar which is a young
property technology company and our
mission is to digitalize the
construction industry so as it's monday
morning i'm having a weekly check-in
with my team i'm responsible for the
sales and the marketing team where
everybody just gives an update on what
their priorities for the week are just
to create alignment in the team so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning hope you're
enjoying it follow me around for a day i
must say this day is rather
representative of how it usually goes
here we are at the office of being
raider i started with this company as a
chief revenue officer earlier this year
and actually if you are interested to
join the team as well building raider is
currently hiring for several positions
you need to be maced in munich though i
will insert a link to their career page
below in the video description in the
meantime i write some emails and get
some work done just in an effort to try
to use the time in between meetings as
efficiently as possible so as we are
rather young company of course an
occasional table football match cannot
be missing we do this quite regularly in
the brakes what i enjoy even more is
probably table tennis so the plate is
most of the time used for meetings there
are many lunch options around the office
so today we decided to go for a shavama
plate which i like quite a lot we
enjoyed it outside in the sun before
then heading back to the office and of
course refreshing us with a nice black
coffee i love to ring lots of coffee so
often just dilute it with water just to
make sure i do not drink too much
because otherwise i would be able to
drink several cups every day which is of
course not very healthy after lunch i
meet the marketing team we are currently
discussing some new lead nurturing
strategies we want to implement so we're
sitting in front of the pc because
several members are dialed in from the
home office and then after this meeting
i met together with another colleague
and we were discussing some strategies
for our events so webinars and other
events that we are planning for the rest
of the year to get us on track on the
marketing side after that i'm meeting
one of the co-founders of building
raider and we are reviewing some
high-level business numbers on the
marketing and sales side and also
discussing some strategic initiatives
that will be now focused for us over the
next weeks after that it's time to get
home using public transit i usually then
sit together with my wife in the
evenings to have some dinner and then
afterwards it's time to go back to the
desk get some additional emails and
paper work done the evenings is often
also the time i use for my firm learning
work so indeed i was editing this very
video that i was filming during the day
so after that i was going back to answer
even more emails many of them also from
you but then it's time to call it a day
and just go to bed so hope this was
interesting please like if you enjoyed
the video and leave me a comment whether
you want to see more content like that
this is heinrich from firm learning
goodnight